Erasmus is this year celebrating 30 years
of bringing people and cultures together.
The programme started out in 1987
when just over 3 000 students from 11 EU countries
took part in the first exchanges.
It has since grown to encompass
Vocational Education and Training,
school education, adult education,
youth and sport,
giving nine million people the chance to have
a formative experience in 33 countries and beyond!
Erasmus Plus has also been instrumental
in paving the way for reform in education,
training and youth systems.
Erasmus Plus has been proven to have
a hugely positive impact on participants.
In Higher Education,
it doubles the chance of participants
being employed just a year after graduating.
Whilst of those who undertake a traineeship abroad,
one in three is offered a job by their host company.
Vocational Education and Training participants
find their first job faster and earn 25 percent
more than they would do otherwise.
Voluntary experience abroad is considered
a plus by three-quarters of employers.
But Erasmus Plus mobility
does not only help with job prospect.
Erasmus Plus has been enriching lives
and opening minds for 30 years.
Let’s now build together the future of Erasmus Plus!